good morning let's see if that works and
I am so impressed that we're all here
given the weather I had to crawl beneath
the turnstile in the subway station
because the Machine didn't deliver
tickets so you know flow Barre this
wonderful French writer has this great
image of bourgeois heroism that's what
this is like to me so I'm mom I'm really
delighted to have this conference and I
cannot say that that the storm isn't
necessarily part of the eco crisis it
could just be your good old-fashioned
bona fides storm so I don't want that
there is a bit of twittering about it
being sort of part of the echo crises
I'm not so sure it could or it could not
open question now before giving I was
going to talk for a bit longer but I'll
make it very short since we start a bit
late I just want to thank a few people I
have a lot of people to thank but I'm
just going to keep it very short the
main person I want to thank is Rebecca
Hogan Rebecca where are you she's not
here just when I was thinking her but
she especially been proeski and Johanna
to copulas I sir our co-sponsor the
institute for social and economic
research and planning that's a very long
name and then so many others who have
helped so thank you very very much if we
could lower these lights just too tight
up front so that these slides are a bit
um are a bit clearer I want to sort of
develop this notion it's part of a prop
I thought more the light of a little
lower here and but in the well whatever
works this is part of a project that has
this title of bridging the ecologies of
cities and of the biosphere and I'm
working on it with Natan doulton who is
a biologist by training which is always
very very helpful to have that kind of
knowledge and I think in fact essential
and the notion is when you look at
cities they are enormously complex
systems their multi scalar they have
Ecology's you know can we begin to use
those capacities to to do a more complex
if you want systemic type of bridging
with the ecologies of the biosphere now
here is sort of a first if you want i'm
just putting a few slides on to to to
actually to be faster about my
presentation so again these particular
features that cities have how can we
really maximize their utilities right
now it seems to me that we are not and
it could have to do with a kind of
economic system that we have a
market-driven logic a very an
increasingly narrow market driven logic
that doesn't help us now if you think
about just a few properties if this is
perfect by the way a few properties of
cities you know they're there they are a
kind of social ecological system that
has an expanding range of articulations
with nature's Ecology's the problem is
that they're negative question for me
and really this is a question other
systemic properties in this event that
now has negative valence that we could
give positive valence so I'm not talking
about destroying everything I'm also
talking about how do we work with what
we have there is a system there there is
systematicity if you want how can we
change its valence now the final point
here you know how can we begin to use
and begin very modest language very
modest hope if you want these
articulations to produce positive
outcomes now another feature of course
of cities is that they mobilize new
kinds of social ecological systems and
here are a few descriptions for me again
the question here is
if they're capable if these complex
systems with fuzzy logic sort of
feedback effects which no central
planner can control if these systems are
kisses are capable of mobilizing new
kinds of social ecological conditions
how can we use that property that is an
interesting systemic property if you
want that they can mobilize these
possibilities and here are just a few
sort of negatives mostly now the fact of
scaling factor scaling in cities is
another one of these um is sufficiently
addressed recognized captured if you
want conditions so on the one hand and
again i'm looking at capability yet the
capability of the city to instantiate in
a very specific a piece of jewelry a
transport system whatever bad emissions
something that actually is enormously
complex that can have a global scale and
the metal of a bus contains within it a
global geography of extraction if you
multiply that so the capacity of the
city almost like an entropic capacity
you know like a black hole it all it
brings it in and it combines elements
from multiple parts of the world again
how can we recover that systematicity of
those capacities and then give them
positive valence same thing and i'm just
using these as examples it is not a full
list of all these thing they think of so
2 co2 emissions so if it's just a car in
the countryside it produces the
emissions but there is no scalar effect
multiply that by all the cars in a city
and you actually get all kinds of scalar
effects you know as on holes bring gases
etc so what we can that final sentence
their effects that go beyond co2
emissions per se
so it's already something different that
is making that is a making that happens
through a multiscale or dynamic and you
can again multiply that by endless
instances in the case of a city how do
we capture that capacity to make but
then of course change its valence now
here's another aspect again these are
all sort of ink little inquiries for me
here's another aspect that I actually
find extraordinary and it has to do with
systems in cities transport systems are
a good example but it could be fully
air-conditioned office buildings that
are capable of transmitting something
microbes diseases or bad things at least
at one scalar better at a higher scale
they might not be so bad but at one
scale without those systems being
affected by them that is an interesting
problematic so how can we recover that
enormous capacity for transmitting
something without having to become part
of the something if you want to levels
of activity again when you begin to
think about a lot of the systems in
cities along those lines you are opening
up windows if you want on to all types
of possibilities it's like a game almost
of recoding some of the capacities that
we see in cities now one way of thinking
about it a kind of summarizing image if
you want is this notion of reorienting
the material and organizational
Ecology's of city so but I just said
about a transport system or machines in
a factory being able to transmit the
disease without being affected by them
is a kind of material ecology and then
there are of course all kinds of
organizational Ecology's now I think we
need to this is my moment of hope here
to to use and build upon those features
of cities that can reorient these
ecologies towards positive interactions
the second point here these interactions
and the diversity of domains they cover
are themselves an emergent social
ecological system that is bridging with
the ecology of the biosphere so in their
lives quite a bit I would say of
potential now one strategy that Natan
daughter and I are using in our research
on this is this notion of this is my
language and people sometimes think I
say delegating back to nature and they
think that because I have a foreign
accent that I may be misusing English
but I must say I really mean it that way
delegating back to nature mind you I use
that language also i don't use mimicking
the biosphere because i do think that
cities are not biological systems i
think there are a different type system
but it has multiple interactions with
the biosphere so one little example that
i love but there are many we have we are
creating a long list of all of these
it's this bacteria and it's both in the
laboratory but it also already has
applications I assume that some of the
architects and the audience know about
it which is a bacteria that actually
likes being in concrete and produces a
calcium that seals the building and has
a double effect it stops emissions
though I can't help with things or what
happens with all the bad gases inside
these concrete buildings but that's
another question that's like a little
footnote but it also under certain
conditions has been found to actively
purify the end not at a very large scale
but sort of immediate air around a
building or a sidewalk that has this now
this is just one example there are many
examples where we could actually use the
capabilities of the biosphere but that
would take a lot of knowledge and that
is why it is not only urban we can't
leave this stuff only to urbanus and
architects so to speak you know we
really do need to bring other other
forms of knowledge into the picture now
wanted to come back to this notion that
that cities are not biological systems I
have been involved sort of inner inner
in a week way but that involved with the
Santa Fe Institute you know which is
full of physicists and I always say full
of physicists who don't do physics they
do everything else but not physics which
makes them actually absolutely
fascinating now one of the projects of
the director George Jeff West who is a
physicist is is precisely to use I find
that for physicists biology is often a
bridge into some other object of study
so I I have had two encounters with him
one when we spoke both you know to his
board of whatever just seasoned and so
he was showing at that point this was
maybe two years ago how in biology of
course you have this incredible
multiscale of repetition you know the
orders of magnitude are very they repeat
so from the amoeba up to whatever the
blue whale the biggest organism and then
he was showing how his cities it also
goes now this was based on an enormous
amount of data gathering every vast
amounts of some of the data that we as
urbanist are rather suspicious of but
you know there's a lot of data on cities
frankly so he show so there is the thing
and then he's a bit there's something
that happens when the city's become very
large but he hadn't gotten there yet and
so I just saw him now at another meeting
where we were together and he had gotten
there and then what he shows with
mathematical formulas etc is that after
a certain size the city does not respond
to the laws of biology hence something
else happens you know you can call it
fuzzy logic systems we can call it
something else now I think that is very
important data that a different sizes of
cities some possibilities can happen and
at a large city the notion that we can
mimic the biosphere in order to address
our problems it's just really not a
ability now another subject of course
that is big on the agenda is ecological
economics which compared I would say to
mainstream economics I don't mean to
offend any economists in the audience
here is in advance it basically prices
equal services I think I have another
one here no this is when it goes sort of
when it home to faiz I think that is
very interesting I think that is a good
way of shaking people up we're actually
using nature's services I don't
necessarily see it as a solution but
again this is a debate so it is
important to recode a lot of what we
take from nature is beginning to happen
with water you know that we are
beginning to price it etc but I don't
see it as really as the solution are
certainly not the only solution to the
sort of the catastrophic challenges that
we face in the biosphere and and here I
thought I just want to do to wrap it up
this is my last slide here what are some
of the features this repeat some of what
I already said what are some of the
features of cities that could help us
regarding this environmental issue so
first one these issues of you know
economies of scale density and the the
efficiencies this is a familiar subject
this I would say is the proposition that
right now dominate a lot of the
discussion about how cities can help the
environmental project and the key
feature there is density the density of
cities and all that it entails the
second one of course is dense networks
of communications the fact that this
means that things can circulate I added
to that other said when I talked earlier
about the buses or whatever other
systems there are multiple systems that
are systems of circulation some of these
are recognizable assistance of
communication others are not being used
as such though the spread of diseases
signals that they are systems of
communication of
now finally this is something that has
gone i would say a bit beneath the radar
screen is this issue of the temporal
dimension that is if you want embed it
in in the question in questions of the
biosphere and I see it as a challenge to
recover different temporality in order
to address also the sort of the eco
crisis if you want finally pretty as all
of this is and the projects that it
contains cities are systems of power
with laws so just I mean this is
something that repeats itself through
history just a rational discourse that
shows us all the advantages how we can
do it and all of that is not going to be
enough it's going to take other forms of
action as well we have to change laws we
have to change systems of authority we
have to change prefer by me we I don't
mean us okay I'm not this is not a call
to action but when I'm saying and these
are for me it's neither is it just
simply a question of organizing
politically these are embedded issues
that is where the question of
temporalities also comes into the
picture some of these are going to take
a long time others are going through a
tipping point as we speak the spread of
urban farming the fact that you now in
New York City you can get a permit to
have your chicken now I don't want to
have a chicken in my apartment but you
know maybe if I lived with a gardener of
the chicken either amazing i do they
actually lay an egg every day or
something like i don't know how they do
that but i find that absolutely
extraordinary so so you know some of
these things are just going to evolve
and run into tipping points other
aspects are it's going to take real hard
work and and this conference really has
a series of of scholars researchers and
activists who have addressed different
elements we are by no means covering
everything differ
elements of this picture so i am going
to stop here to welcome you all again
and to invite our first speaker dr.
Westing i'm going to introduce him very
briefly for me dr. Westing actually
appeared on my radar screen way way back
when i was very interested in the
toxicity associated with agent orange
with the whole Vietnam anyone of us who
were sort of fighting against the war in
Vietnam got inevitably very drawn into
these issues of the destructiveness and
then when i was in central america and
then the destructions their associated
with some military products that say
that the united states was passing on so
so when I discovered Westing's writings
I was it just made a lot of difference
to my thinking to my understanding and
also to how to what are the variety of
issues and it is for me really an
enormous pleasure and an honor that he
could be here with us because I think
he's one of the heroes you know going
back to the 1970s informing us now he he
has been a consultant on issues and
under environmental security to the
united nations environmental program the
in the united nations institute for
disarmament research and other such
national and international agencies he's
a former senior research fellow at the
stockholm international peace research
institute which is a great institute
he's also a member of the european peace
university and a former captain in the
United States Marine Corps and the the
focus of them of his talk is war and its
consequences both own environments if
you want and people dr. Westing
thank you for that wonderful
introduction I have a few comments
before my introductory comments one of
which is that I'm delighted to be here
at Columbia I'm a graduate of Columbia
and this is the first time I've been
back since I graduated so that's a
pleasure for me secondly I'm delighted
to see a number of friends here and also
it's interesting that doctors professor
assassin mentioned her interest in me
was kindled by the fact that I was
working on the Vietnam War and the Agent
Orange issue and I see in the audience a
professor barry weiss Berg who is is
somebody that I was involved with
probably 40 years ago a long time ago
when we were all incensed about what was
happening in Vietnam he wrote co-wrote
and edited a volume called ecocide in
Indochina and I have one of the chapters
in that book so our connection goes back
to that period now when I was asked to
speak that this is the introduction to
the introduction now when up when I was
asked to speak I of course said yes and
then immediately out poured in my mind a
lecture which ran somewhere between 49
and 51 minutes and so I wish a grin to
learn i only had 29 or 30 minutes but
for those of you who are interested in
getting the full picture I do have a
paper that has the full 49 minutes
if anybody wants to see a copy of that
just give me your email and i'll send it
to you and so also it it not only
expands on some of the issues it
provides some nuances although my wife
tells me one of my week sweets is new on
sative ities so what I want to talk
about today is warfare and its impact on
the environment and the effect of that
impact on the people involved and this
this issue gave me a certain quandary
because the topic of this conference is
has two key words in it cities and eco
crises I can deal with eco crises but it
took me a long time to figure out how to
get the word city into my talk so I do
manage however I don't talk about direct
attacks on cities during wartime as
horrendous as those are what i want to
do and also i should say i think that to
some extent this talk will form a bridge
between a conference that Professor
assassin had here a year ago which in
fact dealt with cities and war and so
this in a sense i think provides
somewhat of a bridge between last year's
conference and this one so let me begin
by mentioning four major points which I
think are crucial to understanding what
I'm talking about these are
uncomfortable they're disquieting the
first one is that wars are by their
actual essence
deadly and destructive this is what wars
are all about this is the specific
intent of a war is to be detrimental to
the Armed Forces to the people and the
land of one's opponent so point one is
that wars are meant to be destructive to
the second point is that Wars as far as
we can tell have continued unabated
without break since the earliest history
and prehistory of the human species this
is very simply a characteristic endeavor
of our species the question of war is
part and parcel of our very existence as
a species Arthur Kessler some years ago
had it wrapped up nicely I'll just quote
one sentence from a book of his from the
70s quote the most persistent sound
which reverberates through man's history
as the beating of war drums to give you
some person that's the end of the quote
to give you some perspective just think
back to World War two and the time
between World War two and now there's
never been a year since that period this
more than half a century and there
haven't been more or less than about two
dozen wars going on one place or another
around the world so that's point to that
wars are just with us point three the
third issue I want to say is that oddly
enough counter-intuitively warfare has
not gotten more disruptive more
destructive of the land and people
through the centuries the efficiency
with which war is conducted at least by
the major nations certainly has improved
and keeps improving
however the actual level of damage and
destruction is relatively constant and
I'll hope I can demonstrate that in a
few moments what does limit the impact
of warfare on the enemy is basically
three things one the objectives of the
of the entity that's fighting the war
the will of each of the two parties and
third the tenacity of the parties in
other words the reluctance to capitulate
so it's a question not of how serious
war can get it's a question of how soon
the other side quits and the fourth
point the fourth major point I'd like to
make is that the impact of war on the
human population is serious it's nasty
it's horrible but it hasn't changed much
at least in recent decades in terms of
its magnitude there's been a steady and
ever increasing number of displaced
people as a result of one thing or
another and i'll come back to this later
but the component of those displaced
people that result from warfare or
almost warfare like persecution haven't
changed much certainly not in modern
times what is driving the
ever-increasing number of migrants of
refugees of displaced persons is the
fact that there
resource base is shriveling up is
deteriorating and so it's a combination
of not being able to sustain their
livelihoods where they are and of being
attractive attracted to places where
they think their life can be better
either in terms of safety or in terms of
economics and here is my first mention
of cities roughly half of all the
displaced people in the world in recent
years have ended up in urban areas in
cities so let me now discuss briefly
environmental components of warfare
because after all this is what I'm
supposed to be talking about the impact
of wars one can think of two levels of
environmental impact and some might say
that the second level can be split into
two parts the first level of
environmental impact of warfare of armed
conflict is unintentional or at least
incidental so that whenever there is a
battlefield of some kind the battlefield
itself the theater of operation is
disrupted this is not necessarily the
intent of the of the perpetrators it's
an incidental effect on the environment
and it's referred to in military jargon
as collateral effects and so that's
category one the second category which I
think I'll split into two parts the
second category is intentional
destruction of the environment for one
reason or another
this intentional disruption can be an
attack on farms on fields on forests on
pasture lands on range lands on water
system height without on the
hydrological infrastructure and so this
might very well be intentional and I'll
give you quite a few examples of that in
a few moments so we have unintentional
or collateral and the intentional
effects and now let me mention sort of a
subcategory of the intentional effects
and those are attacks on the environment
in such a way that a modest amount of
energy supplied ends up in causing a
massive form of damage this this
multiple multiplier effect is referred
to in formal jargon as the release of
dangerous forces for example destroying
a major damn might take one or two bombs
and then sweep a huge area into oblivion
or the attack on a chemical factory
might be one small attack and in turn
the noxious fume release might be
phenomenal or one could attack a nuclear
power station again a modest input of
energy releasing a major output of
destructive energy so those are the the
categories of
of military impact on the environment
let me dwell a little bit now on the
intentional effects to give you a
feeling for what I'm actually talking
about and here I'll split them into
effect on the land and effects on the
hydrological infrastructure and here I
could go back clear through history I
could talk about the Israelites and the
Persians and the Spartans and the
Mongols and so on and it wouldn't be
very different from today but I will
restrict myself pretty much to recent
centuries although here I'll make one
exception Genghis Khan in the 13th
century was over running what's now
Afghanistan what might have been banana
stand to parole and remember and he was
Genghis Khan's forces were relentless in
their scorched-earth tactics in trying
to subdue actually successful ease of
doing Afghanistan at the time the reason
I mentioned that is you could hardly
tell the difference between the outcome
of what Genghis did and what the
Russians did the Soviets did during the
their Afghan war of 1979 289 they also
subdued area after area was scorched
earth tactics which you could not be the
recipient could not distinguish between
weather was calm Genghis Khan or some
Soviet Colonel that was doing it
let me go on with a few more attacks on
the land in the thirty years war that
was a nasty war in which the Protestants
of Sweden and Germany tried to work over
the holy Roly Holy Roman Empire and year
after year they used incredibly brutal
scorched-earth tactics throughout
Central Europe but then even perhaps
this was of course in the 1600s then I
can jump ahead to the 18 mid-1800s the
same time we were busy with a civil war
in this country there was an incredible
Civil War halfway around the world in
China there was a group called the great
peace movement which was about the
greatest misnomer of all times the great
the Great peace movement of China took
10 years to find out that they could not
overthrow the Manchu dynasty and the way
the Manchus finally put down the typing
typing is Chinese for great piece the
way they finally put them down as they
basically destroyed everything in three
provinces in the rebellious in the
center of the rebellion and so it took
him 10 years to quiet down the they make
the peace movement into a peaceful
movement this was in the as I say in the
same exactly the same time as our civil
war that was this chinese civil war let
me move away from land now to give you a
few examples of water and since this
place is loaded with people from the
netherlands
professor sassaman teeth are both from
the Netherlands let me give you my first
example and this is the time when the
French we're trying to take over Holland
we're trying to take over the
Netherlands in the middle it mid to late
1600s what did the the Dutch do well
they thought they could prevent the
French from advancing into holland by
opening the dykes on large areas of land
and they produced what was called the
holland waterline in 1670 or something
like that and that was wonderful the
French got stopped dead nobody could
swim in those days but they forgot one
thing and that was winter came along not
so long after and the water froze had so
the French moved on this this was
despite the fact that the local peasant
peasants of the Netherlands at the time
were tried desperately to stop this from
happening but the Dutch defense forces
ignored the pleas of the of the
peasantry and did this anyway and
unfortunately several months after all
this land was flooded the the French
went through anyway let me give you one
more which in my view is the most
spectacular event in all human history
of this sort and this is when the
Japanese were trying to take over China
just before our world war two in what
referred to as the sino-japanese war of
nineteen thirty-seven which merged into
world war two here the Chinese chiang
kai-shek decided that to prevent the
japanese
from over running china they dynamited
the dams of the Yellow River the dikes
the levees of the Yellow River this
caused incredible flooding the flooding
killed several thousand Japanese
soldiers stopped them dead along a major
component of that attempt as I say
several thousand Japanese soldiers
drowned several hundred Chinese ground
several million chinese were displaced
three full provinces were utterly
destroyed the river was finally put back
together again by the way with us money
after World War Two and as far as I can
tell as of a few years ago most
provinces have still not recovered their
pre-war affluence to the extent that it
was so this is probably the largest
single the most disastrous single human
caused incident in all human history
including the nuclear attacks and so on
I could mention World War 2 where there
was intentional rural flooding the
British ruthlessly attacked or
pleasantly depending on which side
you're on here the ruhr valley and
destroyed huge numbers of bridges mind
they filled up mines and so on with
water and so on and so forth the Germans
in turn by the way also did a lot of
flooding in in the Netherlands bearing
so that's enough in terms of examples of
intentional flooding for the moment let
me go to a totally different subject for
a second and that is the explosive
remnants of war by that i mean the land
mines the cluster bomb units and other
leftover ordnance following battles
these are incredibly pernicious they do
whatever they're supposed to do or
during the time of the of the battle
then they stay there for decades
afterwards and people keep bumping into
these mines and cluster bombs that
hadn't blown up when they was supposed
to do and get blown up at the time just
take poland from World War two which was
swept over once or twice or thrice in
World War two a dozen or more poles are
kin are killed every year from World War
two ordinance that they bump into by
mistake plowing or fixing a road or
putting a new color or something like
that and worldwide there the Red Cross
keeps track in there are several
thousand fatalities from past Wars from
these remnants of war landmines and
cluster bombs let me so far I've given
lots of examples what I haven't
mentioned the United States and since
we're all Americans here are most of us
let me give you a quick history of our
involvement in all the first let's start
way back in 1600s and when the Virginia
colonists year by year
maintain the upper hand with the hostile
Native Americans by continually
destroying crops around and about the
Virginia Colony jumping to the
revolution George Washington subsequent
to the war said that his most successful
best planned and most wonderful action
during the entire revolution was not
crossing the delaware it was destroying
the crops of the Iroquois and and and
their food supplies which effectively
ruled them out as important allies of
the British and as I say this is this
attack on the on the Iroquois farms and
fields in upstate New York primarily and
around and about Washington thought was
the most important thing he had done in
the war I won't dwell on the Civil War
or the the Indian Wars when we when we
subdued the friendly natives out west we
constantly attacked their means of
survival and then of course in the Civil
War of Sherman's march destruction of
Georgia Sheridan's destruction of
Virginia and the Shenandoah Valley are
well known so the Civil War is a good
example in the Philippine war that we
had in right around 1899 1903 in there
we were ruthless in attacking various
provinces by destroying their farms and
fields over entire provinces
and they were modeled after these march
to the sea by sherman and so forth and
some of you remember maybe Mark Twain
was incensed by that and wrote some very
powerful essays in one beautiful poem
called the war prayer which was an
attack under our philippine actions our
actions in the philippines World War two
we attack German grain crops with
incendiary attacks the Korean War we
decided that the most successful attacks
that we ever made in the Korean War the
official histories were the attacks on
the dams of North Korea which destroyed
their infrastructure electrical system
power systems and food irrigation and so
on and to get to the Vietnam War this of
course has become famous for its
environmental attacks against forest and
field be here the term that has gotten
into the diplomatic language of
widespread long-lasting and severe that
I'll come back to them a few moments
originated but as you know we attack
forests relentlessly we attract attack
crops relentlessly and we become this is
one of the reasons why so many people
throughout the world were aghast at our
activities and actions and approaches in
Vietnam and that's what got me involved
in all of this to Agent Orange it was
mentioned this is of course a legacy of
the Vietnam War which is still causing
medical effects to Vietnamese to
Americans and to others well
let me get now to refugees I see that
I'm running out of time so I will make
this very quick and say that I'll just
give you a few simple facts that
summarize what i want to say here one is
that numbers of displaced people or
refugees around the world right now or
in 2009 according to official you un
figures is 255 million people who have
left their homes because of one reason
or another now the one reason or another
is important one of the reasons is war
and of those 255 by the way that's four
percent of the global population one of
the one of the components of why is
about is the desire not to get shot and
so this is running away fleeing from war
or to some extent from persecution and
that represents about 14 million people
a year so what does that leave from 255
about 230 million which are not war
involved and these are the ones that one
might refer to as environmental refugees
just one more fact about or two more
facts about those numbers before I leave
them the 14 million give or take a few
million are the ones that are running
away fleeing from war half of them
probably ending up in cities and that
number has not changed at least since
World War two by changed I mean it
hasn't had an upward or a downward trend
it fluctuates slightly so it might be 12
mil
might be 16 million but it keeps
bouncing around 14 million other 230
million not war related that's been
going up in recent years by eight
million a year so whatever the number
was last year it's eight billion more
this year and it's been happening that
way for at least the last decade or so
so let's not get more a bad rap
something else thank you let me let me
conclude now by saying what can we do or
what should we do and there are three
things I want to talk about as I finish
this up and that is what about
environmental disruptions as a result of
war they're not increasing but they're
nasty and they shouldn't be there as I
say they generate something like 15
million 14 million people a year as
displaced people as refugees and
migrants and so on and here we have a
number of treaties the most exciting of
which was in 1977 instigated by the
international committee of the red cross
and it's referred to as the protocol on
international armed conflicts this one
gives pretty severe restrictions
restraints on attacking agricultural
areas dams nuclear generating facilities
and so on and even more interesting and
this is the first instance where
something like this has gotten into the
law of war or what's now euphemistically
referred to not as the law of war but as
international humanitarian law is that
it has made illegal actions that are
expected to cause not that have caused
that are expected to cause
environmental effects that are
widespread long-lasting and severe and
this was the worldwide recommend to the
US after our Vietnam War so let me
there's another one on non-international
Wars which in one sense is is more
important because they're more non
international or internal wars and there
are national international wars on the
other hand that gets very touchy
diplomatically so that's a very weak
treaty so one should support them both
the United States is one of the few
countries in the world that belongs to
neither all of our NATO allies belong to
those two treaties we're the only
holdouts explosive remnants same story
jody williams of putney vermont where
we're from got the nobel prize a few
years ago for being the force behind
having the landmine Treaty of 1997 the
landmine conventions enacted which
forbids a party to even possess land
mines very nice treating every NATO
country belongs except for the United
States there's a much more recent treaty
on cluster munitions which are also
nasty the so-called CPUs cluster bomb
units that only was only enacted in 2008
and things moved with glacial speed or
glacials note slowness so not very many
countries belong to it yet but at least
half of the NATO countries do belong all
of the good nice countries like
Netherlands and Sweden and Norway and
Denmark do belong but again the United
States does not France and Britain both
do so that's one thing we should somehow
or other try to get the diplomatic
forces
prevent these things in terms of
refugees all I can say is the real
problem is is not from warfare but from
civil the civil sector and here i think
the real problem is overpopulation I
won't go into that any further and
finally I just mentioned the term global
warming since this is on the horizon and
everybody is worrying about it and here
again whatever i have said will probably
be exacerbated by the effects of global
warming and so here we really have to
strive for a sustainable energy
consumption sustainable energy
consumption future so that's that's
above it
thank you very very much that was a
great sort of landscape to work off and
work with now I would like to call the
first panel and introduce Rachel
Armstrong who will chair the panel
Rachel Armstrong is co-director of
avatar which means advanced virtual and
technological architectural research in
architecture and synthetic biology at
the bartlett school of architecture
which is the University College of
London she's also a senior Ted fellow
and visiting researcher at the Center
for fundamental living technology which
is a department of physics and chemistry
at the University of Southern Denmark
her research investigates a new approach
to building materials called living
architecture that suggests it is
possible for our buildings to share some
of the properties of living systems so
Rachel if you come and the three first
panelists Rachel will also speak this
afternoon and one other panels I think
we could have some lights maybe and she
will introduce you to
I had good morning everybody I'm glad
you all made it and despite the rain
that somehow or other rain is always a
surprise no matter what city you live in
no matter what city you visit it always
seems somewhat of a shock to
architecture that actually the world has
a variable climate and that buildings
are not perpetually designed to be dry
so as I was picking my way through the
perpetual perpetual and torrent of
puddles and I was struck by three things
one someone needed to tell New York Road
engineers about the invention of drains
secondly that we were totally wasting a
really valuable resource and just
tipping it away into wherever and and
thirdly know that we really do need to
have a more sensible relationship with
the environment and so it's great
pleasure to me to be able to welcome our
distinguished panel today and and even
if they can't stop the rain maybe
they'll be able to advise us on having a
much better integrated relationship
between architecture and the environment
so if I just called the speakers up in
in in order and just give a brief bio
and you've all got more further details
in your in your handouts there there
speaker biographies but I'll just don't
summarize just so you know who's your
speaking and roughly what they're going
to be talking about so the first speaker
and they were going to speak for 20
minutes and this first speaker is a
Chiefs riken and who works at the Delft
University and is looking on integrated
water infrastructure development and as
a design engineer he's commercialized a
balancing product for floating houses
and took it to market and also is
registered patent on modular floating on
a modular floating foundation concept
he's an award-winning writer and he's
currently developing a project for
protection of the Nile Delta M for the
21st cent
so and he's going to talk to you about
cities and floods living on a water
machine so and thank you did you say
Nile Delta
where is the nose
I'm from Holland as you can see it's the
center of the world I like Google very
much they're very sensitive people
before I begin Arthur your point is
already in my pocket with the
vulnerability of the dike system I'm
aware of it but I wouldn't really be
able to say what our current attitude
towards it is so I'm definitely going to
check that out it's a very interesting
point Holland is at the end of the River
Rhine and it's a delta and in a natural
Delta you cannot live because the
borders between land and water are
changing all the time and that's very
unpractical so Holland has turned that
Delta into a big water machine and
benefited greatly from that machine as a
trading hub and fertile soil use for
agriculture however the machine is
sinking down and that also shouldn't be
too much of a problem but the system the
water machine does deserve continuous
attention and modifications because of
climate change but also because of other
changes in society and that's what I
will be talking about let's go to the
next slide yeah i i'm on a great trip
i'm on a great adventure it started two
years ago when influential delta
commission consulted the dutch
government on flood policy for the next
century the result of that committee was
that in 10 years from now the government
will put aside 1 billion euros for
spendings on water infrastructure flood
defence and that looks like a long time
ahead 10 years but it's in fact sort of
normal in infrastructure planning that
you think in those times
in that report was this drawing and it's
a grown-up that I made for with a plan
to protect the Rhine Delta from flooding
and the Rhine Delta is an interesting is
for an engineer and interesting region
because it is the flood protection
system protects about eight million
people about four million in this
particular region but the dike ring
spreads out northbound and it has to
deal with storm surges and High River
discharges and for a particular region
there the coin silence of both those
events and that is what this plan
addresses and the adventure that I'm at
is that the plan is still standing and
after that reports I was sort of I got
you know a nice amount of research money
to investigate it further and how do you
investigate such a such an issue I'm an
engineer by the way although I like
policy and general perspectives on
engineering what we did in our research
is CD system as a hydraulic spatial
connected system that can be modified by
various different interventions here
drawn in red and purple each
intervention combined with a climate and
economic scenario with a climate
scenario leads the so called hydraulic
loads you don't have to remember all
this but this is just a general idea
like how one protects a river delta
hydraulic so it's not as simple as the
sea level rises half a meter so all the
design water levels also rise half a
meter it's more complicated than that
this is just one alternative and just
one climate scenario we're looking at
here next step is what what does the
rising what do the rising water levels
mean for the dikes that that protect the
what we call in ER dike regions from
river water and sea level rise some
dykes are historically higher than
others for all kinds of reasons that
step two step three is there is
something like the outer dike regions in
Holland and that is the region between
the dike and the river and I was in
England the other day and people said
like what is that alder dike region that
you keep talking about and I said it's a
barren wasteland the very air you
breathe is a poisonous fume now it's um
the most of the stuff that's going on
there is its port activity and
regenerated ports in two other goal in
two other functions such as housing and
of course there's a lot of nature and
agriculture going on and the question is
how do how the climate change affect
these outer dike regions important part
of the equation then they're shipping
shipping is not really affected by
climate change at least high water
levels low water levels rns you too but
that's not what I'm talking about now
but different solutions that we can take
to keep our flood risk low can affect
shipping so shipping is another
important part of the equation then
their ecological flows I don't have a
map about that but that's also important
and this is a plan for the sort of
short-term so that first drawing that
you saw would be a solution for 2100 and
what I'm now very interested in like
what's going to be the next step that we
can take and that's in fact a barrier
and the sis a combination of dyke
reinforcements those are huge project so
it's very exciting to work on that am i
addressing an eco crisis here I was
asking myself what could an eco crisis
be I came to a very simple approach
either its nature putting a crisis to
humans or humans could be putting crises
on ecology huh and in water
infrastructure development in Holland
both of these eco crises are at stake
and then there's the same as Arthur
like what about the city's well
fortunately sort of all it is one big
Park City let me just sit back and relax
let me just show you some pictures of
Holland this one of the things that I
enjoy I go out in the country and I take
pictures and Holland is associated with
rain however in fact it rains only seven
percent of the time isn't that
interesting but water is indeed
everywhere this is when Holland is happy
not when the French came in of course
but it's so great you should be in
Holland when there's ice everybody's
happy everybody's making jokes and
talking to each other is great
unfortunately because of climate change
we have less ice here we are starting to
see the dikes this is a very modest
little Thai key here is a dike a little
bit a little bit bigger this is a lake
protecting the inner dike from from from
lake from storm from storm surges at a
lake and here we have a serious guy
serious sea dike talk about serious
dykes what's our attitude towards eco
crisis number one increasing flood risk
one important thing is that we have a
law in the Netherlands dictating a
certain level of protection and the
funny thing about that law is that
actually climate change is embedded in
that law when climate change occurs and
every five years that law is being
updating like there's a sort of a test
going on whether the system is accorded
is updated according to the law or not
and when climate would change more and
more parts in system would be
disqualified and according to the law
that has to be money allocated to combat
that it's not as simple as that because
even though a law dictates that
resources should go somewhere there are
more laws like that and there's a
limited national budget that's one thing
another thing is that some parts of that
law are actually outdated or and a third
issue is that even when the law says a
dike is no longer high enough for
long enough there are more ways to deal
with that so the law looks simple but
it's actually it has some complicated
issues that's the current situation we
have that law then on the long run
there's that Delta committee that I just
referred to that is that has come up
with a with a long-range plan for 44
projects on Dutch water infrastructure
eco crisis number one reducing flood
risk eco crisis number to engineering
works in the past that have actually
destroyed a lot of ecosystems in the
Netherlands particularly the so-called
famous Delta works in the southwest and
Delta what's nice about a estuarine
ecological system are three things first
biologically is very productive there
are a lot of nutrients coming in a lot
of energy tidal energy coming in so the
production of biomass is very large
second because there's a salt fresh
water gradient that attracts ecosystem
and ecosystems and animals that
particularly like this very special salt
percentage and the biodiversity
therefore is large and the third one of
course if fish migration so if there's a
damn the fish cannot migrate up the
river and spawn what I find very
interesting is that the World Wildlife
Fund is active is lobbying pretty
strongly to reopen the dams in the
southwestern delta which would have huge
consequences but so there's we are
working on eco crisis number 2 i'll get
back to that little later in this
presentation hmm what i want to address
also because the the easy thinking about
holland is like moon holland is drowning
because of climate change what are we
going to do about it first it's more
complicated than that and then there's
eco ecology and then there are more
driving forces behind modifications to
the water infrastructure system so you
know that of course but it's not as
simple as the dikes have to be raised
because of climate change is more
much more complicated what I like the
comparison between driving forces behind
modification to the water system and the
mass law of pyramid is that also in the
public sector in the water
infrastructure development there's more
interest in higher functions in the math
lab pyramids such as spatial quality
living with water and ecology or
recreation it's debatable whether you
think that is high up in the mess love
hierarchy or not but let's talk about
that some other time um so we got this
sort of complex but yet limited set of
driving forces behind the water system
what are the issues what I find
challenging is how how much money can we
put in goals that are in the top of the
mast log pyramid I mean in our daily
life we've spent a lot of money on
luxury and identity and that kind of
thing so why not in the public sector as
well issue number two how safe is safe
enough issue number three how to isolate
the climate change factor I think Shiv I
read your article that that's also a
little bit what you talked about like
how do you relate climate change to all
the other factors in related projects so
those are about the objectives and then
there's the the goal to the then there
are the solutions and the solutions vary
in the amount of engineering that they
propose and fear of engineering that's
what we talked about in our email
correspondence saskia is a very
important and interesting issue even you
refer to that today with the engineering
that is going on in New York too I'll
get back to that later hold on hold on
yeah that's not going on yeah exactly so
we have a very funny relationship to
engineering when it works we don't
notice it and when it doesn't work we
complain how to justify or sell
investment in top of the mass flow
pyramid huh I'm going to skip this one
because i thought i had a half now for
some silly reason in the program i
didn't get it this is a difficult issue
what's going on here here we got the
southwest
again the the essence is what I'm
thinking is we have to keep pushing and
keep debating about are we willing to
spend money to improve ecology I guess
as a designer engineer I want to know
like what's my budget to work on that
and then and that's not clear people are
hiding it in other objectives and that's
issue number one um issue number two how
safe is safe enough the uncertainty in
climate change makes it very hard to say
this is the level of safety that we want
because we don't really know what the
threat is exactly and there are other
issues also that that make it very
difficult to sit a hard point of this is
our safety level theoretically the
safety level is an optimum between the
risk reduction and investment to make to
reduce the risk the more precious the
treasure the more expensive the case
around the treasure and that should be
in balance with each other but there are
many reasons why that is actually an
illusion that you can calculate it very
strictly so what I sometimes think is
maybe we shouldn't aim for something we
shouldn't keep calculating so much about
trying to get that objective standard
but we should just think in relative
steps like we don't know exactly how
safe we want to get but at least this
measure will make us a lot safer
everybody gets that then there's the
issue of to isolate the climate change
the vector why would you want that well
personally what bothers me sometimes is
that climate change as a driver for
investments gets a lot of attention but
maybe there are many other reasons why
would you why you would want to invest
also for example an African country
would probe could say we want an
irrigation system because of climate
change but mostly they want the
irrigation system because they need that
to grow crops so you know to keep
reasonings sharp and clear let's try to
isolate that factor now here is going to
be a little bit of math
for you risk is probability x impact and
if probability if the sea level rises 60
centimeters basically in Holland that
means that the probability increases
tenfold if economy would grow becoming
90 years at two percent a year and flood
impacts it would be related to economic
growth that would mean impact Rises six
times so in a sense you could say well
climate change pretty important for
Holland however in an economy that grows
five percent a year in ninety years the
flood impact would increase 80 fold so
for China the ink if you think in terms
of flood risk and you want to reduce
that climate change is not even that big
a factor economic growth is the biggest
factor that increases the risk so it's
important to thinking I would I'm
interested as an engineer to think in
those terms however in Holland since our
design standards were put in 1960 the
potential damage will will grow 30 times
about that multiplied by the probability
growth of 10 factor 10 that's an risk
increase of 300 so that does call for
measures I mean if a risk increases
three hundred fold in a current
environment economic environment that
calls for action how does that work the
I the risk is that there's a storm at
sea river water coming in dike fills
flood how does a water how does a
waterfront look like we have the daikin
than we have that barren wasteland with
a poisonous fume and that the outer dike
in urbanized area dikes do not look like
this you see dykes are urbanized also
though houses grow on houses are built
on the dike that makes it a lot harder
to raise the dike now how it works in
Holland is there is a probability
distribution you also mentioned that in
your paper that I found very relevant
people don't really think in probability
distribution and the law says we have
one in thousand we accept a 1000 or one
in 10,000 probability of a water level
and that it dictates the height of a
dyke now if the law gets stricter
because the impact of a flood increases
that would mean that the dike would have
to be raised if climate changes but the
law doesn't change still the dike should
be raised because of the whole the whole
water level rises you see and what's
going to happen is both so would that
mean that the dike would have to be
raised which is a pain in the bummer and
the bone in urbanized areas now that's
where that plan that I came up with what
that addresses like between is the
urbanized region so the idea is there
you don't have to raise the dikes you
might even the dike I'd might even you
know go down if necessary we wouldn't do
that but theoretically um so we moved
from objectives for modifications in
water infrastructure to solutions to
address that my suggestion is
engineering these these things oh these
things these are these are like hundreds
of millions of so not billion euro
projects do we trust engineering
probabilistic engineer says no don't
trust engineer there's a failure of
probability so probably the designer of
the New York sewer system is saying of
course it's flooding we knew that we
accepted a probability of flooding
because if we would have made the system
larger then the amount of time the
probability of funding would go go lower
but it would cost you more tax
money and then you would complain to so
we have reached an optimum now this is
what an engineer would say and he says
oh yeah you can reduce the probability
of failure we have to research it more
carefully because we narrow the band
width of uncertainty and we can improve
it technologically and the optimal
probability of failure is the outcome of
a cost-benefit analysis between
risk-reducing investment and the risk
reduction that's what I've just said to
and fear is not in the question it's
just the failure probability that's what
we want to know that that's what we
count with that's what an engineer would
say a probabilistic engineer would say
however we built then this thing in
Holland that change that debate a little
bit this thing costs has cost together
with another one that's sorta a little
bit smaller that about 1 billion euros
and its size is larger than the Eiffel
Tower so we have to eiffel towers
floating there and the original supposed
probability of failure with one in a
thousand and it appeared to be one in
hundred and that have major consequences
that changed the perspective on faith in
engineers now let me cut this I don't
have a clock am I like talking for half
an hour yet or I'm only 15 minutes 20
minutes ok now these could also be those
barriers to students of mine and they're
a little bit more sensitive than that
math on barrier that I just showed you
I'm going to jump a little bit now to my
conclusion and i have a small video that
i want to show you i don't know what
you've got and what you didn't get but
the essence of the dutch flood
protection is that it revolves around a
very mathematical core the whole
thinking in terms of finding an optimum
in flood protection and it's quite
extensive and it's really about
probabilistic
engineering and I think their age
rational planning is behind us however
when it comes to flood protection that's
still the core around which everything
revolves and also the funding
allocations but what's happening is that
there are these all these non moderate
like a mathematical policy is I would
call that modernistic right modernism
and so there's a lot of postmodern or
postmodern reflexive iming I'm not a
sociology but revolving around that core
and we have to integrate that nicely
like ecological objectives non
quantifiable luxury country branding
fear distrust and lack of understanding
of fela boat echnology those are not
embedded in that modernistic or how
about political ad hoc Ness politics is
always at hockey but I just like the
word ad hoc Ness I think it's funny um
now now so what are you talking about of
course this is all right this is
happening like the whole issue of
modernism and post-modernism but what
I'm trying to do is to make it more
explicit and even to model it and
measure it and here is my attempts so
I'm working on this series game and the
series game integrates hydraulic model
with a policy model so you don't only
model the physics and the costs and the
benefits but also the way the
stakeholders choose and relates to those
options it's a bit like SimCity you can
you can you can so the the game shows
you the weak spots as they pop up when
sea level rises so the sea level rises
and the dikes are not all like exactly
right so there are some weaker spots and
better spots and poof poof before you
play it you choose your scenarios
because when you would ask me what the
way to go is in Holland is that people
who are involved they have to start to
understand the system also the non
Engineers and then with that
collaborative understanding we have to
choose the next step and then you know
and then in 20 or 30 years there will be
other people who determine the next step
and so the game serves to help
understand and I've been in stakeholder
participation sessions and what I
discovered is that it's very it's great
to have the stakeholders to debate but
it would be so much better if they would
have more knowledge so that's what this
game would address they get a budget
every five years or ten years and they
can build with it and they for example
recognize that you can't build
everything you want if you want
ecological improvement in the
southwestern Delta where do you get the
money from so you get and then suppose
the and I got some money to elaborate
further on days so it's going to be very
exciting because I want interactive
elements to that people who use it they
can send if they disagree with something
if they know it better if they have a
better idea if we lack some kind of
rapport and you can download reports so
here this is a very important screen to
really tap into the pool of knowledge
and ideas and values of everybody
involved
does it do you get the sort of vision
that I have about combining that
modernistic and postmodern mystic
elements yeah we can sort of wrap up
here you see how storm surges and river
discharges correlate with each other and
that gives you the probability of those
hydraulic combinations to get people
some understanding of the whole nature
of probability it's very hard to get
your head around what what probabilities
and chances really are now continue game
quit without sending quittance enter
data and the ideal is that enough people
play it so we can match patterns of
preferences with the profile of the
players and then we have the unity
between sociology and engineering thank
you very much
thank you the next week I'm actually
opting for the saving continue later
budget button button next speaker is a
shiv some sure and who's an expert on
climate change in adaptation develop and
development policy he directs the asia
and pacific regional program of the
International Research Institute for
climate and society and also the
adaptation program of the Earth's
Institute's global network or climate
solution and has helped develop
Columbia's program on climate and
society and now he's going to talk to us
about adapting to climate risks
comparing approaches thank you thank you
thank you the organizers for getting
here following that the brilliant
presentation with extremely kind of
catchy visuals I'll have to plead that I
have none of that this is going to be a
little bit more of a dry hum ho of a
presentation so you'll have to bear with
me and you main really need to focus so
now what I'm going to do is can I just
kind of walk you through the challenges
that are involved in in what we call it
kind of adaptation to climate change and
before I do that because many times in
my ma talks it does come across as
possibly that because of the nuances
that I demand that it may come across
that I'm more of a skeptic so this the
first three slides is to show no climate
change is Israel and we are in it for
whether we like it or not so that's
going to put all of you at ease then
this then the next set of slides would
be really you're going to since I had a
very little idea of the nature of
participants here so I didn't want to
take it for granted that you guys are
already all top notch on all aspects of
weather or climate and so on so this is
just a kind of a very simple quick
run-through
if you guys have already done that you
can just say I love participation so you
can just say next next next and we can
go along so the poor is to just focus on
two case studies Mumbai and Manila and
to basically kind of draw out some of
the issues that are some of the
challenges of having city planning
agencies the key agencies as well as
civil society groups how do you mean in
a practical way begin to address the
challenges of climate risk both of
variability and change so now we will
just go through the first set of slides
oh it's right here sorry I think it took
that from you because we kept looking up
there so now I need to do there you go
ok famous picture this is cop conference
of parties in Bali which is because of
the UN of Triple C every year they the
different countries meet that's a famous
picture of the nobel peace prize of Al
Gore and dr. Pachauri for the IPCC so
well deserved based on this this whole
lot of work that has been done by
thousands of scientists off the that
comes under the heading of the IPCC
which is the inter-governmental panel in
climate change they have three working
groups on climate impacts and kind of
policy what can be done in mitigation
especially and this is to unequivocally
kind of tell you that well the
temperatures are going to be increasing
over the next hundred years and also
there's going to be serious fluctuations
in in precip and that these this light
and this one is not very clear because
they didn't want you guys to squint and
get a headache so the idea is just going
to chill out saying okay science is
their science tells us it's happening
and now we move on okay so if there are
any kind of skeptics would love to
debate but maybe later on after coffee
so for those of you who may be who may
have heard of climate change and wonder
how is it related to weather because
increasingly media portrays anytime you
have a big strong
you have a big kind of Thunder shower
there is always one part of the media
saying oh this is climate change and it
neither completely wrong nor completely
right okay so what we have are these
three distinct systems you have the
weather the of climate variability and
climate change the weather is in the
realm of 1 to 10 days and it's basically
because of atmospheric and land
interactions and science has progressed
well enough that we have really good
skill in predicting weather in most
parts of the world climate variability
is all the way from two to three months
through natural variability goes on
through multi decades through decades
and that is an important component is
you bring in the influence of oceans
that give persistence and hence gear
skill help give model skill okay so then
you have climate change which is
generally several decades out into
essentially or more and there you have
not only the kind of a fine-grain
understanding the physical processes
that are at play on these timescales but
most importantly they're also driven by
socio economic assumptions that go into
as well especially those that govern
emission scenarios okay so it's
important to keep in mind that when we
talk about whether climate variability
climate change there are distinct
patterns of influence and there are kind
of differential kind of model skills
that are that are possible for and again
there is high spatial variability in
this kind of modeling climate
variability and climate change are
related this may surprise some in the
media but they are related that you have
high seasonal internal fluctuations over
the long term is what constitutes
climate change and if you have a linear
trend like they have I just have here in
this caricature even with no
fluctuations no increase in fluctuations
of variability you will still have new
record heights that because the base is
changing so given the last 150 years we
have can effectively ruined and continue
to ruin that Monsieur pumping in all
varieties of greenhouse gases what we
are having now is increasingly in the
coming decades you're going to have more
and more of the
Triple genic influence impacting the
natural variability so that's why when
you have when you ask a scientist okay
is climate change here they always
sidestepped the issue because yes in
some sense it is but in some sense you
know exactly what when person says
climate change is here they're really
looking for this kind of large
anthropogenic influence so you shouldn't
put scientists in that tough spot but
maybe you should that you're going to
sharpen their minds so what we have is
an understanding of variability and
change is really important and of course
now we recognize that is going to be new
highs both kind of return periods of
droughts and and and precip so what we
have is another important set of issues
that would be good to get your minds
around is the IPCC models there are 21
22 23 depending on how you count them
these are projections okay they are not
predictions and this is not to some how
kind of downplay their importance they
are not predictions because they're not
initialized with current climate
conditions so and so this is important
to realize that when when you have this
kind of model runs there are really
projections because what science was
trying to get at is the through the
emissions what is going to happen the
what-ifs because of emission scenarios
but it's really good news is in the next
round which the reports will be out
beginning in 2013 called the assessment
report or number the fifth series of
assessment report of the IPCC they're
actually going to have predictions as
well decadal predictions and this is
hugely important especially for
policymakers okay so IPCC models have a
really good agreement on temperature
increases more or less all of them agree
on the nature of temperature increases
and effects on precept that is both snow
of snowfall and rain is is more
uncertainty of some models that seem to
suggest more than other than others and
of course depending on the region that
you are focusing on this conference then
my cake is is all its speciality
space-based so the bit depending the
region you you are interested in there
are some model disagreements okay but
this is not in any way to kind of doubt
that climate change is is real this is a
quick note for those
fear of perused climate change
literature you'll always have it's not
just the physical the physicality of
science but underlined that many people
miss out is are the scenarios the
socio-economic scenarios that underlie
what the what ifs coming over the next
century you have the more integrated
happy world all of us will be kind of
dancing with joy a more divided world
everyone declares war and everyone else
and so on and each one of them have a
very different emission scenarios
emission of greenhouse gas that are
likely to be put out so now coming to
the question of cities cities and
climate change there are some specific
challenges that we need to confront one
is climate change is is due to dispersed
emission sources it's not due to any one
is due to thousands of displaced
emission sources and you have kind of
complex interactions with socio-economic
it's not just one sector or a couple of
sectors it is a cross all of our kind of
all the sectors that we depend on and
especially the developing countries that
are looking to the west to say okay
that's the model of development it's
very much kind of integrated with what
we want to be based on what we have been
so it is it challenges at a very core
notion of what it means to develop and
impacts vary over space and time in
Rotterdam it would be very different
from say the Nile Delta and it's
completely different from from Jakarta
in the same year even taking into
account the seasonality so what we have
sorry what we have is it's really
difficult to motivate policymakers that
a play space time-based to to take local
action on kind of globally averaged
climate change so what we really need to
have is a much better sense of okay how
is weather and climate changing over
panic Orton put my part of the world say
metropolitan New York okay and then you
have to deal with some of the
uncertainties that were referred to
earlier so it's very clear in the IPCC
reports itself that for especially when
it comes to urban areas and cities the
impact of climate change in the coming
decades is going to be less than some of
the impacts due to the dynamism of the
these themselves and you'll see in my
case studies how this kind of comes
across if not just somehow that if we
did not have trauma change there would
be development Nirvana that everyone
there was sustainable development
everywhere and everyone's there was high
equity it is that the climate change is
an additional driver and it's a very
important critical driver of development
risk in addition to war trade I hate you
or you hate me all of these different
things that that surrounds us this is an
additional driver so it's not somehow to
suggest it's neither to take away the
importance of climate change not is it
to suggest that all you take care of
climate and everything else is different
is ok so that's why I'm a tad allergic
to especially the HTML and Development
Bank always says climate proofing cities
there is no such thing as climate
proofing cities because if suggests that
once you climate proof then you can
forget about climbing maybe did happen
in arthur c clarke saw a Simoes where
you have a very big kind of bubble and
everyone kind of is under that but most
of us have to manage risks so it is
really the risk management that is
really critical and that was no big at
you i did see climate proof down there
but that that was really for Asian
Development Bank so what we have is
cities have two kinds of responses
mitigation and adaptation and today I'm
going to focus on adaptation there are
experts at the Earth Institute who do
both mitigation experts as well as
adaptation right now I'm just going to
focus on adaptation which is kind of
managing to bring in resilience to
cities and this is now emerging as a new
priority internationally because the
focus was all on mitigation how do you
bring down these greenhouse gas
emissions and even now despite a focus
on adaptation the funding levels of
adaptation globally speaking of very low
then order of magnitude lower and these
are the pledges and by the time the
pledges actually turned to real dollars
you lose another 100 so adaptation has
ways to go in actually getting the
resources and as you will see getting
the focus both of science and policy
makers the stakeholders for local at
patient or the agencies that provide
basic services households communities
and what I call them as the partial
partial because there's always kind of
voice amplifier such as self-styled
community organizations NGOs and they're
a whole slew of NGOs gong goes bingos
non goes there are a whole bunch of them
depending on who finds them and then you
have a first elected officials then each
one of them can have are always all of
us are for who cannot be for citizens so
but all of us have a partial
interpretation of what citizen really
wants or needs or should have in fact so
those are the stakeholders and you have
the motivation is to protect series as
well as livelihoods it's not the
physicality of the city's only they
concern about it's the economic system
the livelihood system both in the now
and in the future that is in the future
after 100 years which has been the
hallmark of climate change discussions
and but for policymakers israeli in the
now next week next season next possibly
next year a couple of decades out so
there are kind of very very specific
kind of location specific challenges to
how much we know what we can do one is
that the temporal and spatial climate
downscaling itself globally there is a
pretty good skill on climate change
scale but when you try to downscale it
there are there are some real issues and
so scientists are working on it and this
is an area where climate sceptics would
have to believe would have you believe
the row we need to wait for until better
knowledge it comes along that would be
completely the wrong approach you need
to work with what you have and i'll show
you the way we do work at Earth
Institute on this and so a key emphasis
is the understanding of current climate
variability the wiggly lines you saw you
have for the last 100 years data that
can actually give you a pretty good
handle on what is likely to have a 30
years out and then you have the to deal
with the sources of uncertainty this is
not only of uncertainty of climate but
also socio economic trends if you only
step back and think about how hundred
years ago New York was could you have
imagined a planner actually projecting
the needs the demands for public
services can in in in the city and here
I think they did a pretty good job but
in most parts of the world you have
planning always is an ex post ever
planning catches up with reality
planners go out and so this is no longer
a green space then I better go back and
change then it becomes I don't know semi
urban space so you have a very different
approach to to to planning and this is
further heightened by issues of
vulnerability vulnerability is not just
because of climate but it becomes it is
because of who you are that is where do
you live in the city if you are a slum
dweller living in a shantytown you have
much higher probability of being flooded
then a person who lives on the
seventeenth floor in a modern block of
apartments which has all the kind of the
kind of flood proofing that is that has
been the finest engineering can buy so
then you have the where and the when
also dictates is dictated by who you are
what you do what are your kind of
spatial pathways in the within the city
so it is not somehow that city as a a
monolithic unit can be climate proved so
we have two contrasting kind of urban
cases one is Mumbai flood management
Bombay now called Mumbai and
metropolitan manila and the key lessons
that we kind of draw out our that
currently institutions that manage
kilometer s both in the weather or
seezle and interannual and longer time
scales are extremely reactive and what
you need to have is opposite is
anticipated a risk management that is
what is needed and so there is a lot of
emphasis in kilometer discussions about
the need to have better forecast and
this is very true because we better
forecast better skill you can do a lot
but forecasts alone are insufficient you
really need to understand how
institutions work what are the
incentives who are the stakeholders and
all of that is an extremely kind of date
it's it's not an easy set of processes
to model so here you have simple just a
couple of in the School of Architecture
planning I felt I had to put up again
some maps we have greater mumbai and you
have metro manila mumbai you should you
may know already is just a collection of
islands that was built up it was
actually pretty much man made it was
made by think it's
original seven islands and so the
potential impact of climate change and
Mumbai is completely unknown what could
happen because of the impact on
hydrological level and hence what would
be the impact on Mumbai it's totally
unknown and it's each one of the kind of
the nightmarish kind of scenarios for
Mumbai in 2100 just a quick run through
metro manila and greater mumbai there
are compared abilities but they have
grown at different kind of speeds you
have a population beginning and then in
kind of in the 60s and 70s comparable
and then by the time it came to 1975 you
have 11.2 million in manila and the
mumbai is around 14 million Mumbai is
slightly bigger and greater in terms of
the metropolitan population land area is
comparable and what is really
interesting is this one which of course
most mumbaikars would would agree but
the government of india which would
totally disagree is that you have over
60 close to sixty percent of of people
living in slums and spotter settlements
in mumbai and this is from a government
source itself so this was not some
didn't go out with NGOs who love to kind
of kind of bat up these governments so
and whereas Manila has done a much
better job of having only thirty percent
that means they've had large-scale
housing and people may disagree in
everything that housing is really bad in
Metro Manila how many of you have been
to metro manila our lovely okay so each
one each section has one that's good so
the housing is not exactly the best and
they get flooded out but still you have
housing but unlike in in Mumbai and then
you have the percentage of households
with access to pipe water again is other
small in in Mumbai just over forty
percent a pipe water and the total
rainfall is pretty much the same but
what is important to recognize here is
in the metropolitan Manila area the
rainfall is in two distinct seasons so
it spread out over so that is the same
amount of rain but there is less rain
per month on an average whereas in
Mumbai it is just in the southwest
monsoon period beginning in kind of
early June through October you have
a fairly huge amount of rain coming down
so quickly we walk you through these two
case studies Mumbai is known for its
flooding in fact it would be really good
to have if there is a there is tourism
in India for especially that used to be
from the Middle East for people who
would go to India to look at the monsoon
they were kind of changing the monsoon
how many of you have read alexander
fraker is really book good book on
chasing the monsoon so now you have a
lot of Middle Eastern folks coming in to
just feel the monsoon we should also
have an annual pilgrimage to Mumbai to
look like a flooding to see how how
little a human being learned from from
our own mistakes so this happens so all
I'm saying is flooding in Mumbai is a
normal affair Mumbaikars the people who
mumbai are pretty much they're ok with
with flooding because the sake well
that's one of the costs of just living
in Mumbai ok and report after report
talks about how coronal how every year
you have chronic flooding in big parts
mum of Bombay and especially of the
commuting lines the railway lines and
but as a result of this it is a very
strong institutional mechanism they've
done a really good job of actually
putting together a really good
state-managed disaster emergency kind of
response system that does that works
well and that is when there is a
disaster so this emergency response
system and mom the Bombay is one of the
finest in the world where as I can just
a test that all of these arrows do work
and you have the fire the police the
Civil defends the army they all kind of
really do come together when it really
matters and so and this is as a filter
on enterprise it is a really good one
it's really good and now that has been
some opening up to bring in NGOs and
CSO's and so on okay so I my sensors I
think we can get you can get copies of
this so not to worry so you can get
copies of the presentation that is my
presentation so but what happened in
2005 if you know was a Bombay Mumbai
experience unusually heavy rainfall in
24 hours in a matter for me for arts you
almost had one meter of rain
so and a lot of scientists kind of went
crazy trying to figure out how has there
ever been a historic precedence and some
of them came up with the SES that has
been but it hasn't been but clearly in
modern memory that has never been any
such or a meter of rainfall ingestion in
24 hours and this led to a key arterial
old flowing neatly river which is now a
big drain but that kind of old flowed
and the suburbs 12 15 feet of water I
mean it's just stunning some of those
you may have seen some of the pictures
it's just amazing that you have three
story building half of it is underwater
and the only reason this road is in
India the buildings are not the slums
and squatter settlements but the
buildings that are built are made with
the brick and mortar you don't have the
wooden structures that we have here in
as residential places so they did stand
and you have for a financial capital of
the country this is simply unacceptable
that they had over 600 630 people dead
tens of thousands of residential
buildings and commercial buildings had
to be negated and for months at a time
so the economic loss to the to this this
to the city and hence to the country was
huge in the billions of dollars but the
key to note is I think even more
catastrophic impacts could have happened
if not for the emergency system so this
is not going to beat them down to say oh
you guys didn't do your job well I think
they did a brilliant job in taking what
could have been a far more kind of
catastrophic impacts and turning it into
something that even though it's
unacceptable at least had kind of face a
semblance in the scale of deaths had a
semblance of yes there is a certain
acceptance even by Mumbaikars so the key
findings after this there was a whole
slew of studies following a disaster
it's it's almost kind of a it's a kind
of a sociological need to have studies
all over the world so you had depending
on you had like 15 or 20 different
studies funded by different people and
but the keys the key findings were
interesting the key findings were a
combination of what is climate and non
climate but this part was not recognized
the key findings were all of them said
oh this is because of climate change and
then also because George Bush was
was the president here that in health
matters the gal kind of said oh look
because of the guy we're all having all
this this trouble jodha protocol and so
there was a massive amount of public
debate on what countries developed
countries need to do for on climate
change because this is a manifestation
of climate change impact that's
happening right in our backyard in
Bombay but also the key engineering kind
of more engineering minded studies went
into and looked at the drainage and that
was a person that was completely
inadequate drainage that was over 100
years old was designed for 25
millimeters per hour which again as
you're ready poner is a cost-benefit
ratio okay if you could have a one meter
per hour drainage but the thing is it
costs a lot more and then you have inter
generational equity issues coming up so
here it was 25 millimeters per hour and
this there's one meter completely
overwhelm the system but even more
important was the drainage was designed
when you had most of Bombay was not
built up but over the last century lot
of the Bombay what we now call as Mumbai
has been built up there is massive land
use changes that the old the holding
points have been built over and then you
have encroachment of slums there is a
lot more concretization that has gone on
which means there is in there is a huge
increase in in water flows which then
the drainage system has to handle so not
only the drains were not designed well
enough there are four just the one meter
of rain even if the rest of the system
is ok but you also had the land use
change that impacted the resultant an
even more kind of flow of water so that
was kind of Mumbai to highlight how its
reactive how they move from one crisis
to another and the ability to step back
and look at the whole system is is very
difficult for them they would rather
point2 oh this is because of climate
change and then we need to do something
about climate change rather than say
okay we really need to climb very
differently in a very different light
you have the reactive urban management
again in uncut hunger is supplies metro
manila water supply it's a hugely
important damn it's not one of the
largest reservoirs in mid-may and money
lie to another in in Philippines it's
one of the smaller ones but it's hugely
important because it supplies
ninety-seven percent of water to metro
manila
and it also has a modest amount of
irrigation water 30,000 hectares and
also has supplied some hydro hydro power
to the Luzon province and helps control
floods but here well I think we can skip
this is just to show that in October
through December it gets most of the
inflows El Nino many of you have heard
of the linear la ninia they are right
now going through a line in your face El
Nino is this is just Central America so
this is this is the Pacific so when you
have a heating of the Pacific the sea
surface temperature rises beyond a
certain level then it has what what
what's known as their linear and this
has global implications for climate and
this is a naturally occurring phenomena
this has nothing to do really with the
climate change climate change may impact
El Nino and it will behave very
differently but some people are now
especially some of the students that I
have sayo alenia that's because of
climate change Lynyrd say no no no El
Nino is a naturally occurring phenomena
and here this is just to show that El
Nino happening in the Pacific actually
has important teleconnections rest of
the world and I also use it because it's
a pretty arresting graphic so what
happened here is over the Philippines
that part of the Philippines where I
have hunger there is in a linear period
that is the huge decline in in rainfall
leading to loss of water flowing into
the reservoir and because of the policy
of impounding water for metro manila
even though it was it was raining early
on the farmers were told no for water
because the metro manila it really needs
to to have have water so there was no
irrigation june through december of all
of 97 and all of 98 there was no
irrigation and the farmers i'll walk you
through the system where they're
supposed to be compensated but they
don't get compensated no power
generation and then because el nino 97
turned into 98 la ninia they had too
much water and so the to protect the
safety of the dance they raised and they
had to spill the water so the farmers
got flooded out so you have
the system is based on a well worked out
a rational kind of engineering based
kind of rational decision-making system
which is what happens here on on the
kind of the top of the slide that you
have a very well worked out system where
you have a Technical Working Group which
is highly skilled comes up meets every
month to comes up with what this should
be the nature of the water release from
angot reservoir and that is supposed to
what is supposed to happen but actually
what happens is and this is this is all
under the Philippine water code what
actually happens is and this is not a
corruption of the system because there
is a sense that when people study
developing country institutions if they
don't work as you expect them to their
sense of either they're inefficient or
they just simply no good or that's kind
of corrupt making money on the side or
just not even being around in their
offices this angus is a really well a
well-run system but what happens is
power has power plays a huge role in the
way the system is managed and in this
case is very simple the philippines the
center of power is its metro manila
unlike in most other parts of the
developing world the rural areas in the
philippines don't wield too much
political power it is metro manila and
its populations and once they metro
manila get folks get underage and they'd
walk out to the street the president
pretty much has to scoot so so what has
happened is that the policy has been to
keep water to hold water back for metro
manila because you do not want to ration
water for metro manila so you keeping
water for metro manila even if it is
raining and even if then no even if
there are four castes iri forecast
suggest that you have to release the
water they don't because they want to
avoid they don't have an incentive to
take that risk okay and you have other
aspects that are detailed out here how
each one of these institutions have
their own stake in how to run uncut and
then depending on who wins out every
season you have the farmers mostly
getting shafted they never get kind of
enough water and the Philippine water
quote suggests that the farmers need to
be compensated but there is no
regulation and they're not going to have
any regulation because they just don't
have enough money in the FN key key key
to be compensating farmers for four
okay if they don't get water so powerful
institutions each one of them in their
own interest externalize the costs so
you have the power of metro manila to
safeguard water resources they always
invoke water scarcity under the
Philippine water code even if it's
raining univ it's normal and the farmers
are not compensated and as a result
farmers experience high variability of
water but what is applied to metro
manila all these years have been fairly
stable and increasing so then the
question is what happens when you have
hunger in a climate change scenario
which you have worked there with them
and it's interesting that we need to
then take into account not just climate
that is changing but also the growth
scenarios that is the growth of Metro
Manila projecting out you have increased
water demand plus the increased
frequency of dry spells which is which
is most likely going to happen will lead
to declines and water availability and
continued language changes plus increase
in about normal will result in flooding
so they're going to get both some years
are going to get drought somebody's
going to get flooding and again the same
thing is increased paved area as it
happened in Mumbai can lead to less
groundwater recharge hence can lead to
flooding but the key is even if you
model hunger and even to run hunger in
the best possible way that science
demands hunger can only supply water
there is a supply threshold by around 20
20 so then even if you have anger run in
the best way you will not have enough
water for all of the multiple uses so
it's actually right now that you need to
begin to plan infrastructure at least 20
years in advance way ahead of the system
knowing full well that there are certain
uncertainty or uncertainties associated
with not only the climate but also the
socio-economic front what's the
population per capita the very
aggressive they want to actually have
far higher per capita water available
for the Manila folks but the key is that
we're going to have on that alone is not
going to do and focusing on climate
change alone is not going to be solved
the problem for metro manila now the
last two slides so adapting to climate
change you need to really have a set of
kind of core issues core values one is
you need to integrate with existing city
planning and my
engine processes not to kind of somehow
have that tabula rasa sayang Oh
everything is clear let's start with new
institutions okay we really need to have
what are the existing institutions what
are what is the the way the manage risks
you need to include benefits for today
as well as the future you're going to
lose your policy makers if you just
focus on 100 years out okay because
that's two generations out and the focus
is really on the current generation so
you need to be inclusive of time scales
and you need to have on the science side
you need to have spatially congruent
information on climate that is congruent
to decision making you can't have global
scale models to to help you better
manage Manila then there is a whole
series of institutional incentives
inertia that one needs to kind of begin
to explore which we have done in our
work and as the previous speaker is
saying we need to deal with
probabilities there is no such thing as
a certainty that this will happen this
year this will not happen it's all the
probabilities and hence really key is to
focus on the intra and inter
generational equity when a talking or 50
years out infrastructure who pays the
people who pay now so what's in it for
them so that kind of participatory
planning processes really are at the
heart of how to adapt to climate change
for in our work at the Earth Institute
and in the Institute where I men iri we
have a whole kind of lot of these
specific projects and efforts globally
all over the world and you since you'll
get a copy of this and you can also
should feel free to go to our website
and quickly skim it's just how you can
improve better manage improve climate
risk today identify possible kind of
scenarios especially over five to thirty
years where there's a lot of policy
traction and continually integrated the
updated information whether its climate
socio-economic into your planning rather
than say okay we need to wait for so
rather than do kind of just modeling
exercises we do a lot of actually
working with policy makers we don't have
we have a lot of project then actually
work with policy makers in early warning
system with IFRC which is a global
project we have agriculture in India
fired early warning system in Indonesia
a really good one in malaria early
system in Botswana and now there is a
new one that they have just introduced
earth Institute's it's it's a really
good program on global network for
climate solutions it has both a
mitigation component as well as
adaptation and Scott parrot many of you
may know is leading the mitigation
component and this denti project is led
by as a Jeffrey Sachs so all of these
are available on the on the web at
Columbia and Mike your participation and
maybe during the discussion if you have
an issues or if not later on so thank
you again thank you for that compelling
talk the next speaker is Richard Matthew
and who's associate professor of
international and environmental politics
in the schools of social ecology and
social science at the University of
California Irvine and founding director
of the Center for unconventional
security affairs he's a world authority
on the environmental dimensions of
conflicts and peacebuilding and he's
been extensively published
well it's a pleasure to be here and and
they should I should probably start off
by saying that most of the work that
I've been doing and I don't use the term
global environmental crisis or
catastrophe slightly I sort of agreed to
to that title for this talk and thought
I'd think about a little bit but it's
not a term that I most of my work is has
been in very specific areas I've worked
as a researcher and and for quite a long
time with the UN's post conflict and
disaster branch and it's been working
congo sierra leone rwanda nepal and
pakistan those are the five areas where
I've spent a lot of a lot of the past 15
years so I have a bit of a bleak view
about the world I've seen the tremendous
strength and resilience of people
operating under very adverse conditions
but also have a sense of of the huge
challenge of redirecting or reorienting
global trends that that play a role in
in reproducing and intensifying some of
those adverse conditions but I haven't
talked much about or at all about global
environmental crisis I'm going to talk a
little bit about these these things up
here and I want to start by saying you
know the past the past couple of months
we have seen an awful lot of disasters I
think the earlier speakers are quite
correct climate change scientists do not
say that the massive flooding in in in
Pakistan China India the fires in Russia
all from from August that these are that
these would not have occurred if there
were less greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere what they do say is that
these things are consistent with the
types of weather outcomes that they
would expect from climate change and
there's tremendous confusion about what
climate change is for some people this
is an enduring change in the statistical
characteristics of climate for other
people there is no comparison group this
is a unique phenomenon d they look at
they try and build a comparison group
with you know massive asteroid strikes
and volcanic activity
that eradicated ninety-five percent of
of you know the biosphere millions and
millions of years ago and as a result I
think that people are often quite
confused about is this climate change or
is this not climate change after 15
years of intense efforts to educate the
public we discovered that a lot of
people still aren't really sure what's
global warming what is ozone depletion
what is air pollution that a quarter of
the people in the US Court of the people
in Britain are skeptical that is even
happening and that in this country
roughly the same number of people who
think gay marriage is the greatest
threat to our national security believe
that climate changes so there's there's
a there's a lot of confusion i'm not
going to but i think that there's
there's there's an enough disaster that
we don't have to determine now whether
it's caused by climate change or
something else and if we look here at
what happened in in pakistan as the
flooding of the indus river in august
and you know these massive amounts of
rain falling in cities like Peshawar in
a 24-hour period and really as earlier
speaker talked about Mumbai you know
huge amounts of rain falling in very
short periods of time and causing in
this case we know some some 21 million
people to be affected a fifth of the
country's land surface flooded million
homes destroyed you know and so on and
so forth so we see these these these
youths things are they will they
aggregate into a global environmental
disaster I'll talk about that sure they
also return back to here certainly urban
areas are vulnerable to lots of things
they're vulnerable to pollution they're
vulnerable to resource scarcity they're
vulnerable to the things that we think
of as climate change effects they're
vulnerable to massive numbers of people
i spent quite a lot of time in Katmandu
i just earlier this week try to confirm
some of these numbers with a colleague
of mine who lives there and and is known
for this work and he was telling me that
right now kathmandu has about three and
a half million people in it many of them
driven because the into the into the
into this the capital because there
aren't livelihoods for them
elsewhere but the infrastructure of the
city can only really serve about one and
a half million people there are two
million people too many and as a result
sanitation's overwhelmed water is only
on for a few hours a week energy you
know is there are lots of blackouts and
people take to the streets and they
protest when they're watered when they
don't have water they set car tires on
on fire and they cause massive traffic
jams and so on and so forth this is cat
man do you know and and and these images
of air pollution enough of trash are
really very very common you don't have
to go very far in Kathmandu to to see
these sorts of things elsewhere in the
I've spent a lot of time in Rwanda if
there's if there's a group of people who
might qualify as the worst of people in
the world it would probably be pygmies
in the great lake region this is a pygmy
flood camp and what end this is 18
months I 18 months after they were
flooded out of out of their homes so you
get these sort of situations where their
disaster they move people another
disaster comes up the country's
resources shift the people continue to
to to sort of be waiting for assistance
Goma another city that has spent a lot
of time in the Congo and and you know
years after the the volcanic explosions
in city is still is still waist-deep in
lava and that's only one of the numerous
problems that have been a plague this
part of the world water shortages I just
took this picture a few months ago in
Sierra Leone where you have you know
enormous enormous problems are these
linked to climate change I don't even
think that's that's the key question
right now the question is what are we
going to do urban areas are very
vulnerable to all these sorts of things
they're also related to their also
contribute to these things right now we
have we we have half the world's
population living in urban areas but
they are responsible for somewhere
between 65 to eighty percent of the
consumption of resources and of the
generation of greenhouse gases and of
ways so we have a small you know we have
clearly an inequity here you're probably
familiar with the ecological footprint
literature and it points out that a city
like New York draws down
the resources in the 8 million people in
New York draw down the resources of an
area the size of France London the
resources that it you it utilizes
require an area of 120 times its actual
size so as we see the trend and of
course demographic trends are are not
predictions they're they're just you
know this is a possibility but we can
see as many as 3.1 billion people being
added this is the median the median
prediction to urban areas over the
course of the century before before
population stabilizes as as some
demographers expected to do so these
things cities play an enormous role they
are driving force between behind
resource scarcity behind pollution
behind what we understand to be climate
change and biodiversity loss and if you
look you I'm sure anybody was travel
through the world here you have you know
small units that ourselves that are
largely self-sustaining and their
footprint is much smaller than that
looks like my place in California sadly
although I don't have a swimming pool
but it's you know but but the footprint
of urban life is is very very large
maybe a hundred to two hundred times the
actual land that's available in urban
areas so okay what given we have this we
have this problem where urban settings
are vulnerable to all sorts of
environmental problems and they're also
contributing to these can we be talking
about a global environmental catastrophe
catastrophe is generally defined as some
sort of large-scale disaster and
disaster I'm sure you're all familiar
with it but it's a function of you know
if an earthquake in Antarctica is not
considered a disaster if it doesn't
affect anybody or any you know any human
values I'm so it's a question of how
vulnerable we are and that depends on
exposure so so you know if you're asking
how vulnerable are you to skin cancer
are you exposed to sunlight or you're
sensitive do you have very fair skin and
what sort of capacity do you have to
protect yourself you have access to send
to 10 screen and so on and so forth and
clearly geography and wealth play an
enormous role in determining
ability right now the biggest the
biggest migration is into coastal cities
and coastal cities are largely located
in areas that are particularly
vulnerable to a lot of the environmental
challenges that we've been outlining it
also seems that you know generally
speaking the poor have considerably less
capacity to reduce their vulnerability
to these things can we imagine as a
disaster on the scale of yeah what
planetary disaster will some people do
but i do want to give you an example
this is a picture I took in the summer
of a of a village in Sierra Leone which
is on a mining concession and and you
know as the mining company has expanded
it is moving these these people who have
lived there for many generations into an
area which is extremely vulnerable I
mean they're moving them into an area
which is which is has exposure to every
sort of problem the people are saying
well why we're not going to go we're
going to fight them but ultimately they
are going to go they are going to be
moved into this area where they're
exposed to disaster there are sort of
three views on whether we should be
talking about global environmental
disaster there a group of people who
think that we should tad Homer Dixon is
famous for this so wuz yo Wilson at
however sort of saying we are we was
never there talking about we should be
talking about about what are we going to
do because we are well we are already on
that pathway we probably have already
crossed critical thresholds the driving
trends towards this environment global
environmental catastrophe are are
largely immovable we have already seen
biodiversity loss take place we were
already seeing greenhouse gas emissions
take place we were already seeing things
we are in this great the sixth great
extinction that is already underway
we're already there so we should be
thinking about recovery from this as it
as it gets worse and worse but for
people who are in a state of denial and
still saying well this is a manageable
problem or is only one of many problems
we have the economic crisis and we have
we have disease curtains and we have
terrorism this is only one there simply
they're simply not looking at the at the
data accurately they're simply they're
simply trying to contextualize and every
discipline is trying to contextualize
these problems in a way which makes them
seem smaller and manageable when they
really are the problems are actually
enormous and they really should be the
focus of our attention you have another
group of people sort of diametrically
opposed Bjorn Lomborg is famous for this
you say yeah these are real problems but
you know the fact is this is not the end
of the world we're going to be able to
adapt we're going to be able to innovate
we're going to be able to deal with
these things we should not over invest
we should not dramatize we should not
dramatize the problems or over invest in
the solutions we should accept that lots
and lots of signals are coming into
communities at different levels and
communities are responding bit by bit
and the future is not at all bleak
there's a third year last on Tuesday was
at the State Department doing a briefing
and I gave a briefing about about the
environmental situation apply it and the
person behind me was an economist and
there were three of us during these
briefings and he said he said listen he
said it's very interesting all this talk
about environmental change and climate
change but he said and I like the Latin
he's referring to me he said the last
speaker had some interesting things to
say but let me put this into context for
you the overall trend of the planet is
extremely positive Asia is recovering
rapidly from economic crisis it is going
to it is going to continue to recover
what I predict is decades of strong
growth in in in in China of Indian
Indonesia taking off but we should be
doing is position ourselves for a very
very vital and growth-oriented global
economy and these problems we need to
put them into context they are affecting
yes millions of people sounds dramatic
but their millions of very poor people
being affected out of billions of people
who mostly are doing fairly well and so
we don't want to overstate and and set
and then this view I it's not a view
that is is out there is as easily
because it sort of says the conclusion
of it in the conclusion of this
this person's briefing was what we want
to do is try and keep that those
disasters localized as much as possible
we want to try and keep the micro level
phenomenon and not let them see pin we
learned from SARS what happened SARS
stars imposed enormous economic costs on
the planet and countries like Canada
Canada said hey there are advisories
don't travel to Canada don't come to
Canada right now they said we are not an
exporter of SARS only one case of SARS
has been exported from Canada we have a
fully under control in our hospitals in
Toronto it is completely under control
don't stigmatize this was during the
height of the other countries if they
said the problem there mate you put some
restrictions on travel to Thailand or
China if you want but don't don't pull
us into this economic nightmare because
we're not we're not exporting to we're
not exporting SARS it is not a problem
sepang we are and and and the view of
these economists was we've gotta
maintain that situation we can't let
these dramatic moments sort of color our
Paul are our policy decisions and so on
we've got to be able to to do what it
takes to contain disasters and not allow
them to become global phenomena not so
much in the and the EO wilson Homer
Dixon sense where everything dies but
more in the sense of economic shocks
rippling through the entire system
posing bigger and bigger costs on us
cost the today or in the tens of
billions of dollars cost the could mount
if we don't if we don't allow if we
don't you know contain them into the
hundreds of billions or trillions of
dollars if we're not careful and so
their advice was look it is not pleasant
to be poor an equatorial today given the
sort of environmental stresses that we
face but but don't let this divert us
away from the very very happy picture we
have of a planet that's living longer
and making much more money climate
change is going to impose great costs on
some people but create great
opportunities for other people it is
going to open up resources is going to
improve productivity and in Canada and
parts of Russia and the United States
and parts of South America and Australia
and we should be looking at we should be
very careful the key is damn
control and if you look at it you look
at the disasters this is a disaster shin
the most recent period i could get a map
and you see them heavily heavily
concentrated in certain areas if you
look at the countries that are most
vulnerable this is 2010 list of the
countries that are most vulnerable to
environmental disasters a very sort of
predictable group of countries in many
ways because of their conditions because
of poverty because of the capacity to
reduce vulnerability what isn't
suggested what isn't it there yet is the
argument that that cities have a large
role to play in determining the future
and that's what I want to suggest here
i'm not i'm not taking we're going to
take a position on whether we're already
well into a global catastrophe or
whether we have multiple ways of
adapting to this or whether really is a
question of if you're poor and and in
the wrong place life is going to be
really rotten over the next 50 years but
if you're rich in the right place it's
actually going pretty good clearly when
cities have have some potential they
have enormous capacity and leverage to
shape some of these outcomes urban
design could be and this is an argument
that you don't hear very often in policy
circles in fact you don't hear arguments
about environment climate change it to
the senior post circles anyway these
days why that is it is hard to know but
but the focus is on the economy just as
it is here but urban design does have
this capacity to to to operate on sort
of the same time frames that saw those
medium-term those multi-decade time
frames that that business and government
are not able to do and so we can imagine
cities making the decision to reduce
their environmental footprints
dramatically we can imagine them
focusing on ways to reduce the
vulnerability of those people who are
living in the slums or in those cities
that are poorly positioned to to so that
such as their vulnerability is much
greater through basic development
strategies and better use of scientific
information a climate proof in a term
that doesn't mean climate proof
it means it means taking steps that
reduce some of the expense abated
impacts of of because you obviously as
we've learned we can't be climate
provement but there's this is not a an
end state this is a process mitigating
the harm the other thing I think is is
this is that what we have is a system
which has found itself found very clever
ways to displace the problems and in
either either to project them into the
future or ditto slice them into areas
where people can't resist them very well
and isn't just sort of putting our are
dirty plants across the border into into
Mexico it is generally speaking we have
found this this is and I this image here
we have a small village in Sierra Leone
a few years ago was an agricultural
village price of gold went up in the
world market and so people stopped
farming and to turn to gold mining they
made a little bit of money but they
exhausted the gold mining and now
they've got to basically of destroyed
environment no more gold and no idea of
what to do and so we met with them they
said we don't know what to do where we
have no we have absolutely no prospect
right now and this woman said will you
take a picture of me and make sure you
include it and she said gold mining used
to be a woman's occupation Sierra Leone
it was you know a way in which we built
up some insurance and in case of
disaster and when prices went up men
took it over now it's exhausted and we
have it and so we're doubly
disadvantaged we've lost our historic
insurance policy if the agricultural
potential the region is destroyed
because of the mines we don't know what
to do there certainly is the sense of
you know the world market having these
dramatic impacts on the micro level I
think it is an important question
whether we like the economist friend at
the State Department whether we feel
that we can tolerate that that's that's
acceptable that's an acceptable level of
collateral damage to basically a very
robust global economy or whether we're
going to do you know try to do things to
reduce that and I think that that that's
we have gridlock in most of the capitals
of the world so cities are going to play
a role in deciding whether whether
whether how they're going to be involved
in these global
processes I think there's a huge sort of
unexplored opportunity for cities to
start to become conscious of their
linkages out of the ways in which
they're linked to the rest of the world
and how they want to how they want to
manage those those connections and
whether they do want to focus on
protecting green wealth out there and
focus on on you know using their
critical mass to make green technologies
viable and using their leverage in areas
like procurement to shift the economy
and and these sorts of things whether
they want to reduce their footprint
reduce the vulnerability of their poor
reduce their tendency to displace
problems into into the weaker areas of
the world thank you very much and like
everybody else I'll be around for
questions
right so I'm I was just looking for
Saskia they see whether or not we've got
time for do we have time for a few
questions to the panel or we we we are a
bit over time okay fantastic so other if
the panelists em just come back onto the
table just take a few questions in the
audience and then ask the panelists to
respond to to those ones they would like
to respond to okay so there's a is this
error is there a roving microphone at
all who are we going to I failed object
to my Vista is a roving microphone okay
and there's a question down here at the
front
just take another couple of questions if
there are any other any more in the in
the auditorium there's one over here and
gentlemen the green shirt
okay and one last question is there
another another one okay well I'll just
dis summarize those so that's either
and/or totalitarianism and implementing
strategies for climate change in cities
and the other one is mostly feed black
back loops when thinking about complex
engineering problems specifically within
within cities so if I just ask the panel
just starting starting with you yeah
yeah I've been thinking about that it's
a going around a lot they call it the
spiral of risk I you you protect
yourself better so you invest more
potential damage grows and the risk
would increase mathematically that is
not necessarily the case but try to work
it out for yourself and but and socially
when you when you how do you call that
unwrap the reasoning I I could sort of
say to you like why are you trying to
get ah you're probably like a bigger
room and then a house and then you buy a
house and it may be a bigger house and
then a nicer car and and base and I can
say well but then you become more
vulnerable because you can lose all that
what are you doing why are you doing
that and maybe you do think that that is
actually your honor maybe you don't do
all that but I do I like you know I
honestly I like you know to live well so
don't you think that that's actually
this issue that you're addressing so my
response to that is we're caught in
spirals of risks facing android on the
question of authoritarianism there's no
doubt that open plural societies
probably are vulnerable
sorts of ways one to certain types of
transnational threats because of their
openness and second you know in
mobilizing and effective response
because of their of their pluralism so
that it is hard to come up with an
optimal climate policy in the United
States when you have so many competing
interests that a government has to be
attentive to on the other hand they do
have an enormous stock of innovation and
vitality would think of social
entrepreneurs and social pioneers and
this type of movement and a tremendously
powerful sort of citizenry which has
technological skills are tools that are
unprecedented in a way we have the most
powerful generation of citizens in
history even while we may have you know
a government that it that that is is is
very very very difficult to take on big
restructuring big perform types of
projects whether it's in health care for
climate change your education Orioles so
it is not clearly it's not clearly the
case that that a pluralist democratic
study is the wrong place to be i think
that that there are strengths and
weaknesses to it it nor is it obvious
while singapore could could respond very
quickly to sorrows and did so in canada
had a much more difficult time doing so
it's not clear that which was ultimately
the better the better route and I saw
that China which has enormous problems
is going to be able to solve it it's you
know in internal tensions more
effectively than then the United States
can so i think it's it's if there isn't
a clear victory i do know that some of
the people like like Homer Dixon who are
associated with thinking that we're
really well into the crisis feel that
you know if we had a more a more
technocratic group of elite to managing
things and with a little bit more
freedom that we might we might negotiate
the future
I'll take the same thing a little
bit differently in a couple of ways one
is given the sheer diversity of reasons
why we got where we are and the
diversity of impacts that climate cannot
plays out as one of the key drivers that
evolved when do you have all these other
development risks I think totalitarian
as and as a system of governance would
be the very last thing we should be
thinking about because I think one of
the failures of the UN f triple c the UN
system is the search for one single
large policy that I think is now finally
being in a given up because it just
means very different things to very many
different people across the world
reducing greenhouse gas emissions for
Australian farmer is very different say
from a farmer in Sierra Leone to a
utility manager in Bolivia to one in New
England so that they mean very different
things so so that so that's I think one
but the second would be and this I can
have toss it back to you the the very
approach that all of us have bought into
which is development is progress and or
progress is development with a capital D
that itself is total and totalitarian in
its scope vision and we have at the
margin people kind of talking about well
we need to work differently we need to
her different former development and I
think that so far has failed you can
generate the kinds of real-world
policies I think there's a lot of very
good debates going on in academia but
for many reasons it has failed to kind
of get in to kind of policymaking and
one of the most interesting innovations
now is in Bhutan and I think many of you
from Colombia may have heard the
discussion by the Prime Minister
up is this idea of maximizing gross
happiness okay which for many many
reasons we initially because it was kind
of people reacted with with a sense of
are these guys for real must be there
must be a lot of marijuana there so
these guys are clearly out so even in a
World Bank IMF circles they've got a
sense of dismay but now it's interesting
how in in the last 15 20 years there has
been can study in roads made into kind
of serious economic policymaking as the
idea if not just of economic growth
which we all rejected even though we all
wanted to Human Development Index all of
us would like to have a better quality
of life human develop HD eyes of you and
DP and so on but now the next big jump
in policy is okay what does it mean and
this is not in the psychological sense
of what does it mean to be happy how we
condemned or Freudian view of happiness
or unhappiness this is really material
basis of happiness so maybe that's
another way to kind of look at how to
get out of this kind of totalitarian
vision of what constitutes development
okay thank you or we're going to have to
wrap up now so I'm just going to
summarize cities and eco disasters what
can we do well today we've learned the
term firstly it's complex and pan
disciplinary secondly cities do play a
very important role especially in medium
term solutions and transgenerational
approaches and finally scientists are
actually willing to make the move from
projection to a projection prediction
but only after the main calendar has
completed its cycle thank you very much
I'm come back at one thirty and we'll
start the afternoon session then please